ma mi metto qualcos'altro sul braccio
vado a vendere cose nella metro e da
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo video
sono fa vj e come in ogni sabato siamo
in un nuovo blog poteva ricominciare
ragazzi con le news e tutto il casino
solito volevo dirvi ragazzi in questo
blog ho fatto una collaborazione con lg
per il 9 quando sto gesticolando ho
fatto una collaborazione con lg per il
nuovo lg g5 che telefono non avreste mai
detto quindi ho fatto delle scenette
vabbè poi vedrete tutto volevo
annunciarlo all'inizio del video prima
di cominciare il come al solito di
ripartire con la frase a settimana e la
settimana scorsa quando c'era il momento
della fara della settimana ho introdotto
la von alta e tutto il casino e alla
fine non l'ho messa quanto possa essere
stupido da 1 a famigila fra della
settimana è stata vinta da irene che ha
fatto sto disegno bellissimo che volevo
mettere anche la settimana scorsa
perdonami rene per non averla messa la
settimana scorsa però il soggetto della
fan art ha un quoziente intellettivo
pari a quello di questa tastiera siccome
sto per andare a fare delle scene epiche
faccio un cambio di fisher momentaneo
quindi ragazzi passando all'attività di
lg che vi avevo descritto poco prima
allora la lg mi ha inviato il nuovo lg
g5 ed è il nuovo telefono della lg io
avevo g3 prima il g3 romania g55 is
magic e 3
il telefono ha delle caratteristiche da
paura tipo il design metallico e un
sacco di altre nove [__] che poi vi
faccio vedere per non descrivere in modo
noioso così come se dovessi dirvi una
tiritera infinita ho preparato delle
scenette con dei giovani ospiti maggio
vini proprio vi lascio al video perché
secondo me fa spanciare ve lo lascio
giostra
si stoppa e allora facciamo un altro
gioco ragazzi ce l'ho io gioco per noi è
un pilota no il nuovo wired delle leggi
di cinque ma almeno le doline si vedono
non ho molto meglio puoi provarlo certo
[Musica]
tifo quanto è grosso gesù io io io no io
non ce la posso piu fare a vivere da
solo di ragni non ce la posso fare
uccidere mi fanno schifo
no no la batteria da parte di sky gianni
la batteria
[Musica]
ecco la nuova batteria rimovibile
ecco difetti o ragazzi facciamo una foto
i ragazzi non ci sta che tutti sappiamo
aspetta aspetta ci penso io
ora che figata sa cosa è visto non hai
visto ancora niente
[Musica]
e la camera speciale 360
sapete che vi sto trovando tutti perché
questo è un video speciale trollate
entro 60 e quindi entra ghazi ringrazio
tutti coloro che sono apparsi in questo
video e ci ho messo una vita a montarlo
è però è stata una figata incredibile
grazie anche alle g per la
collaborazione con quei camion i t shirt
lo contestualizzato per il fatto che le
scene non ho girate oggi ma avevo girate
prima non c'eravate arrivati da soli ma
è comunque ragazzi per fare chiarezza ma
il gadget che ho inserito nel tè fano
non serve per mettere il grandangolo
perché il grandangolo c'è già nel
telefono serve per tenere il telefono
come se fosse una macchina fotografica e
cha la rotellina per lo zoom serve a
quello mentre ragazzi vi lascio in
questo momento la notazione da cliccare
per vedere il video in 360 che ho fatto
che se siete sul computer basta cliccare
col mouse per girare la visuale così lo
vedete bello figlio mentre sono guardate
dal telefono si vede così certamente
girare tipo il telefono così si gira
tutto e dove lo spoiler e basta ma devi
sparare rilascio annotazione da cliccare
così diventa più figo solo guardate voi
anche ragazzi passando al prossimo punto
che anche questo epico se vi ricordate
ragazzi nello scorso blog avevo
introdotto il fatto che sono andato da
cattelan a the pcc che sarebbe questa
trasmissione di sky dove condotta da
cattelan appunto praticamente avevo
fatto il ciapi bunny in diretta tv la
tragedia siccome non avevo ancora le
riprese questa settimana invece cielo è
ve le faccio vedere questo è stato
chabib anni che ho fatto in diretta
televisiva con cattelan e la mia dignità
e finita nel cesso prego una delle
penitenze più comuni tra voi giovani
youtube hairstyle chabib anni corretto
corretto in che cosa consiste la bbc
aveva anni un intelligentissima sfida
consiste nel
cercare di tenere in bocca il più
possibile il numero di marshmallow si
tentando ogni volta di dire una frase
che in genere e ciao ciao
noi proviamo a fare questo gioco però
dicendo social facebook è il sacello
face ad ogni giro ognuno di noi deve
mettere il marshmallow si può che dire
socialfake uno di noi due morirò se
questa cosa la guarda mia madre è mai
stato preso prima
allora facciamo insieme insieme sul
divano mai social fei social face
ma secondo social face social sono anche
i giganti che certi opa grande vai ti
odio social facebook social face era il
mio sogno che dire in televisione così
face social face che stupiti anche vuoi
[Applauso]
fantasmi
doc miti tono gruppo angelini le guance
[Musica]
all
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ieri
meraviglioso vedevo l'ora di farvi
vedere queste scene dovesse ragazzi
passiamo allo scarto dei pacchi visto
che è arrivato il momento di aspettare
un attimo è che stavolta va beh partiamo
da questo ragazzi che grosso grosso
partita di tester per che cosa cento a
game tester ogni tanto mi mandate ste
robe che non capisco il perché che bello
dei giornali vita mi mancavano i
giornali perché ce la faccia che sembra
sembra in ecstasy stato un gioco della
uil
grazie grazie grazie no questo è
veramente figo e dopodichè ragazzi cè un
per un attimo che avevo fosse un furetto
morto però non è quello è un buffo ma
quanto è figo
[Musica]
noi di terra del russia beviamo acqua
minerale tutti i giorni perché un giorno
dei ragazzi cè un pacchetto con su
scritto per fa vj le contiene invece
mancavano secondo me ragazzi mio braccio
si sente sotto sequestro da qualche
giorno cioè che cazzo passiamo al
prossimo che molto più grosso poi james
the best ten che non ci ho messo una
vita e mezza professor of attapirati
codice che c'era un pacco nel pacco
tanto per cambiare uno scrigno senza la
chiave però non c'è destra chiave se non
trovi la chiave prova a scassinare il
lucchetto e zia io i grimaldelli sa
usare solo ed esclusivamente su skyrim
che bisogno c'era
a eccolo staccato sono uscito a
staccarlo c'era questo la mia vita è
fottutamente completa che ora vi sono
anche tagliato grazie mille zia per la
ferita d'arma da fuoco e proseguiamo con
l'ultimo pacco presso sì che mi mancava
furbi anche poi la cosa divertente
ragazzi è questa
c'era solo furbi valais ragazzi il collo
e ferite di guerra direi che possono
concludere qui il video prima di
concludere volevo farvi una domanda se
seria questa una delle poche volte in
cui è seria avete presente a ogni che
dalla serie che sto portando avanti
adesso siccome mi piace un sacco genere
di quella serie lirico siate un gioco
più o meno simile da fare una volta che
sarà finito a ogni dove lo chiedo perché
da mi piacciono veramente un sacco le
storie horror quindi fatemi sapere
quindi ragazzi spero che i video
è piaciuto e cosa mi è piaciuto solo un
commento è un mi piace anche a parlare
di facebook con la descrizione cioè se
questi disegni ci vediamo al prossimo
mito bene ragazzi
[Musica]